good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
please allow me to welcome you to this
edition of our 2020 2021 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain
institute the college of arts and
sciences the school of data science and
through a grant from the national
institutes of general medical sciences
i'm absolutely delighted to introduce
our speaker today dr adong zhang here
from the university of virginia here in
charlottesville virginia edong earned
her phd from purdue university in 1994
and is currently the william wolf
faculty fellow and professor of computer
science with joint appointments in the
department of biomedical engineering and
the school of data science here at the
university of virginia her research
interests focus on machine learning data
mining bioinformatics and health
informatics she has served as the editor
in chief of the ieee transactions in
computational biology and bioinformatics
journal she's the founding chair of the
acm special interest group in
bioinformatics computational biology and
biomedical informatics
where she served from 2011 to 2015
and she's currently the chair of its
advisory board she's a
founding and steering chair of the acm
international conference on
bioinformatics computational biology and
health informatics and served in that
role from 2010 until fairly recently in
2019
again her research interests involve
machine learning data mining
bioinformatics and health informatics
and specifically dr zhang develops data
mining and uh deep learning machine
learning approaches to modeling and the
analysis of structured and unstructured
data with a variety of applications
especially as it pertains to biomedical
applications
as uh is the theme of this year's um
biomedical data science innovation lab
um dr zhang's presentation today is
entitled metal learning for biological
knowledge transfer as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for
recording via youtube and if you're
watching on youtube thank you so much
for joining us today also our specially
selected 2020 2021 biomedical data
science innovation app participants are
very much encouraged to submit any
questions for dr zhang via the chat
feature in their zoom sessions i'll
synthesize these questions and ask them
on your behalf during the last 10
minutes or so of the lecture and with
that welcome a dong thank you so much
for doing this we're really looking
forward to hearing your presentation
thank you
jack
thank you for inviting me to be here and
i hope you know i can be helpful for
your
lab
so anyway uh so today um
i will focus on the
machine learning part uh
for bioinformatics and health
informatics
so hope uh
to talk about new things which may be
helpful uh to the
lab
people
so first of all i hope
uh to mention that the machine learning
and deep learning
has been popularly used
in bioinformatics
and
due to
multi-omics data in
different
you know cases like a cancer or other
diseases
so we have uh plenty of data available
uh so
uh
so people start to use the machine
learning deeper and new to the main
purpose of using that or the main
function this can do is to integrate
different
modality data
into a uniform representation and you
can do prediction
so
with that uh
we start to think about you know what
are the challenges
in this direction so
so
to apply the diploma into this uh
medical and biomedical domain
we do have a very challenging problem
which
is called the big p small n problem so
so what do we have is
we we have an enormous amount of data
but each cohort so we normally have a
small number of samples but each example
has a high dimensional features
uh so that's called a big p small n
problem
and and moreover you know in in the
image
with the images so you have a spatial
relationship
but so so
convolutional neural network normally
can work well with
with that but in in the general uh omics
data you don't have that spatial
relationship in the input data so so
these are challenges
uh to apply
the the dependent approaches in about
biomedical field
so uh with those challenges uh our goal
is to design
uh you know uh design
uh
not normal models that can accurately uh
predict
uh based on the less training data so
that's our goal how to predict based on
the the
small amount of training data
so
uh you know it turns out that
normally we can do this
customize the deep learning that can
incorporate some domain knowledges into
the
more accurate
uh prediction so
so with that i
just
hope to mention one paper republishing
the top ai conference top
triple ai
we
published the paper which shows how to
utilize both labeled and unlabeled data
to train a different new model uh to
make a accurate prediction so in there
the central idea is to how to make a
attention putting layers inside of deep
learning to
make the the model faster in converging
to a to a prediction model so that's one
of the recent work we have done but
today i hope to
talk about the new things
in machine learning and how this can be
applied to
you know our field and we can
design some some uh projects in the lab
uh coming in june
so so the new trend
here so currently
if you you have uh got into the deep
learning so you you know you know
in order to train a different new model
you need a large amount of data
to do this but we as i said we don't
have that much data in each cohort so
although we have a lot of data in
general but then we look at how human
man thinks
you know even a kid
does not learn things
with a huge amount of data so you can
learn things very quickly you know if
you know you how to ride a bike you you
can write a motorcycle
you know learn how to write a motorcycle
very fast
and if you seen cat and bird you can
easily you know just a couple of times
you can easily
quickly you know tell them apart so this
is a human so it turns out that you see
human
uh does not learn things based on a lot
of samples just a few samples and in
reality in biomedical field you do have
the scenario you know you have a big
data but it's a long tail uh
shape so small data are more common
so
with that
um
you know the machine learning field has
advanced a lot and so uh i hope to show
what people are thinking right now so so
so basically you have
a few images
and then you just want to train you know
tell show you this is a bird this is a
dog this is cat and then you can giving
a dog and birth you can see this is a
dog this is a cat right and in our
biomedical domain if we have a few
samples in different diseases and then
give you a new patient
you want to be able to detect whether
this person is this disease or that
disease
so
so this latter
with limited training data so what is
our
uh
you know go here the the the interesting
research
you know has been going on is
transferring so to transfer uh you know
knowledge from other domains to the
domain you don't have much data
so transfer learning has been going on a
lot so the latest one is a methodology
so
learning how to transfer so that is
one of the things
we we
look at so what is the matter learning
uh so mediterranean uh as the new uh
research topic in the con
the machine learning domain it's saying
we want to
mimic human learning by training a
machine model on different
learning tasks
so but each task only has a few samples
okay and then so the machine can learn
to quickly adapt to the
environment with new tasks
so that's basically
what we are training the machine so to
mimic how human learning
so
to change such a model to quickly adapt
with a few
few examples
and that is
a lot of challenge how you would do it
right how you will do it so
uh a good uh
so uh there are there are different i
will skip this one
however
to next one so how we do it so uh
basically i want to use
this example i borrowed from a blog
you know it's a good example to show how
this works
and uh
here as examination rather than going
through the uh the formal you know
processes so basically you have
uh you know if you are familiar with the
machine learning models you train the
model using a lot of data now
i don't give you uh you know a lot of
data to train mode i give you a lot of
tasks
so you can have a thousand thousand
tasks but each task
has a training superset
um
and a query set so for example training
pascaline has a
this is called a n equal to three means
n way which is a number of classes so
you have three classes k two means uh uh
two samples so each class has two
samples
even anyway
uh two two chart so this is uh
what
when people are saying and me so each
task i only have
two samples in each process i have three
classes and the query said this has a
one from each class
okay so then the class the training task
the two
can have a totally different
samples from the
task line so for example you can see
here are the darkest
uh
uh dolphin and
lines so these are very different from
the task line so so you have a thousand
such tasks to train you model
and then you have to test the task
similarly you have a superset and you
have a query set
okay so with that
uh so you train the so so each time you
use a task
and
and then you use the query so the
machine
can
look at the the support set
and the query said to quickly adapt
to detect the query set and then you use
the second task to quickly adapt so
uh in the end the model is not trained
for any specific task it's trending in
general to detect to adapt
to the new uh environment
so
when you train the your model can do
this then when giving you a query task
with only a few samples then you can
quickly adapt your model to detect
uh when given quilt
okay so that's generally what the metal
learning means so it's trying to mimic
how humans learn
so with that
i hope to mention there are different
versions of metal learning uh you know
in the coming from the
machine learning community so the memo
is the most famous one uh from berkeley
and uh
and then you have a few charter learning
methods
these are all different methods
and so i will use the meta memo as an
example
uh to show
to to show how it works so so basically
uh i as i said you train the model to
quickly adapt
so what
does that mean in terms of the
parameters in the model specifically so
you can see here if this is what we want
to train right and then using those uh
support tasks we quickly adapted to each
environment
uh
this small
delta errors you can quickly so with
this adaptation quickly you train this
data
so eventually after the training you got
a theta which is your matter running
after method and the model which is
supposed to be able to quickly adapt to
your environment so then after that
when you are given new tasks
so with just a few samples the sita can
uh quickly adapt to statewide star
citizen two a two-star citizen in
different environment
so if you're familiar with the transfer
learning this is a similar uh concept
that means we will learn a good
data in the model which can
easily adapt or fast adapter to
different environment
okay so hope that it's clear on what the
basic idea of what the material is
um
recently so measuring here has been
applied to computer vision a lot uh so
very popular approach so but
recently in the past two or three years
it has started to to be used in the
biomedical domain so here i uh i
referenced the
two papers
they showed the uh metal and outperforms
regular transfer menu
in their paper and with data the second
one has a
a significant work from stanford um
so basically they are showing the
metadata using method you can transfer
the knowledge from uh
different cell types uh so you can
adapt it to new cell types with just a
few uh
samples okay so uh i would specifically
mention this paper because you know
you're doing a neural uh
neural related
research in this lab so so this paper
applied the metallic to
uh the alzheimer's disease so basically
uh
this paper oh
so i'm using their slides so it
seems automatically
moving so this slide
they actually use the amnesia
and the dimitri and the parkinson's
uh
samples as they're supported by me then
you you they use the mci which is very
close to alzheimer as the support
and then uh so to train the model using
this is three uh
uh samples which are similar but you
know in the same category but a
different
kind of different disease to train the
model to extract the the common uh the
parameter which can quickly adapt then
eventually use the
alzheimer so
that's what they they design
so in
uh so
back to to the to the page to the slide
so in this
uh
you know they have a slightly different
uh design because they use the mci which
is a more closer to the alzheimer to as
a test
domain to first train the model and then
adapt it to alzheimer's so in their
paper
uh
uh so they use the two so here's the
data they used
uh from oregon health
and uh so the you can see from the data
set they have a
dementia and ammunition so these are all
not
a lot of data so case and control so
each of them you know
you won't be able to
you know train a deep learning model
with each individual cohort but uh with
the way
designed here
uh using the source domain to train them
to to train the metadata model
they are able to
use this
uh initial and
dementia data to train the common
parameters which you can quickly adapt
to the alzheimer's disease
okay so this is uh whether they
experimented so with their result
reported from the paper so they they
compared with a lot of
uh supervised uh
learning models uh so including all
these logistical regression k n uh
random forest so so these are all
popular approach uh people use and then
you they also use some
other basic uh meta renewal approach
and they showed the uh so their
metal cnn and the matter uh lstm
so you added the metal learning uh
process into the model on top of cnn lc
lstm will do much better
uh in the prediction of diseases so so
they they they show the result like
like that so uh so so so the this work
uh showed that uh the metadata is
effective in the biomedical applications
so with that
we also published a paper uh you know to
show how meta-renewal
works for tcga
so if you're familiar with the tcga this
cancer
genomic uh adolescence so it has uh
over two to twenty thousand primary uh
cases uh cancer samples uh both control
and and uh
disease cases and they have plenty of
features so they have genomic they have
epigenomic transcript atomic
all pro
proteomics they have all these features
so so the features are enormous it's a
high dimension but if you look at the
although they have a 20 000 samples
but if you look at the each category of
the cancer so these are different
cancers in there so they have a 33
different type of cancer
but if you look at the each cancer the
the
the samples are quite small the largest
is just over a thousand so
it is not
practical to train
any of these cancers using the diploma
model because the the samples are too
small right
so
uh
so so how do we uh you know utilize this
in in prediction models
so we look at it carefully
and so so you have all these different
uh data types and features
and
then we we apply so so our goal is to
to perform cancer prediction
so so here
uh so we in order to do that we utilize
the
uh label the the
samples from different cancer
set
and so for example here you have a the
brca cancer you have
this gb m cancer and this different so
these are the phone name of the cancer
and
then
applying the same metadata uh process
so we train
uh so so we form a different set of
tasks
with
each different kind of cancer we can
form small tasks
and and then we can train the metal new
model and do matter tests and and then
form a
a model which can uh quickly pre
adapt to the new cancers so that's the
the idea
so you know a little bit more deal i
i i'm not going to show the
formulas but i will show this picture to
illustrate
the idea so so basically in in in the
episode is the term they use the in the
machine learning community so
in each of the inner group you you train
the model using tasks so these tasks are
from different cancers so each cancer
you probably use
just a few samples and then you can
train it
to
quickly adapt
to the to the query
to predict the query and then in the in
the outer group you use the uh different
tasks to test
and then it can so so so this train this
data will adapt quickly
with the new uh testing cases and then
with that you you gotta so you you
gradually train a good
theta which is you can use to adapt to
any new cancers
okay so so this is a what
is applied to the to the tcga using the
mediterranean framework
uh with that
so the trinium set up in in our
environment
uh so we have
uh all these different data so we use
the 31 cancers
from the so so there are two i think
too small and all another
you know
good cases to be used
so we we randomly selected 21 cancels
and
then
we use the validation randomly selected
five cancels and then the test in case
we randomly see like five cancels
and so so
with that the result
we tested with different features so
first
using just the proteomic features as the
the features of samples
and then we
we have this many patients from 31
cancers
and three way five way means that we use
three classes
to train the model
and it means three cancers each time and
one shot means each time you have
three classes one sample in the class
and three shot means three classes three
samples
all five classes one sample and five
samples
okay so with a different scenario we see
how it works so we compare them with
different metal and new method and also
pain and random forest
and
so we use the so manual based
uh perform the best
in the scenario so these two the metro
network and the pro uh prototypical
network also are metallic methods but it
looks like a
memo based it works the best so
here you can also see when you have more
samples in each class
it does perform better so this one has
five samples in each class and you train
the model it does perform
better so that makes sense rather you
have more samples in in each
task you can train model better so these
are remarkable uh you know
result from
using the metal renew to do the
prediction
um so we also use the um you know more
different you know set of features for
example this one we we also
including the
rna expression data
so we have more features and then did
this so with this
features the more features
included it looks
it's performing better
and even reaching 98
accuracy in here so uh that feature and
uh
if we also use all features including
everything in tcga the available
features
then actually the performance
dropper a little bit because so so you
can see some of the features are not
useful or duplicated or noisy so so we
we saw those
noises so so this
is what uh it's showing
with that
so so
uh it is uh quite in you know
encouraging to use the method to extract
the common uh
you know good
transferring capabilities to transfer to
new cancers uh industry so we've shown
that other people also shown that
so with that
you know the current research whether
current research
we are interested in
so we want to
not only just purely use the metadata
approach
you know uh
the machine learning community design we
also want to
integrate
knowledge from the biomedical domains so
the
issue is how you will integrate
the domain knowledge into this process
and uh so
one thing we can look at
is domain knowledge
from the back graphs so for example in
in image you can have this hierarchical
graph
mammal to dog a dog have different dog
cat different type so from patient data
you know just look at the uh
nervous system you will have a different
kind of
uh disorder or
degenerative nervous system and
alzheimer's so this belongs to different
categories so you do have such a
ontology
as knowledge you can use and you can
incorporate that into the
systems so
uh
so so with that we look at the you know
mimic data so mimic data is a clinical
data so these are you know including
mostly the icd-9
diagnosis called uh and
lab uh
lab testing uh result so
uh mimic data has a lot of disease
and a lot of features too uh to be used
so with that
we the reason we use this is because the
mimik data they call the
the coded based on the uh disease so so
the code actually
indicates whether uh other categories so
so for example
nerve they have
three numbers and go to phone number
this is indicating different diseases so
in the
hierarchy so we can utilize we utilize
this uh in the metal immune system
and to to to narrow down our uh so so so
i will not go to detail this is a kdd uh
paper uh in kdd20
paper we published so i will just show
some result so with those
knowledge integrated into the process
we can
we can show that
so this is a tada that is the one we
included
into that
learning model so we can search we can
we can narrow to the different
ontology relationship so to utilize
those relationship
uh you can see
uh
our approach perform better than mammal
so previously we showed the mammal-based
approach
how to perform this uh
approaches
uh matching network prototype so you can
see they basically memo works better
than this
in the example but ours works
much better because we utilize the
domain knowledge in the process so here
sample sub graph sampling means we
sample the data
in based on the sub graph definition so
if you only sample based on so so here
and random sampling uh cases so here is
what it means if i sample
the
tasks based on the sub graphs so then
they are more similar so it's more
difficult to distinguish between them so
if you randomly sample
among the graphs then they are more far
away and easier to distinguish so in
that sense why
when you use a subgraph sampling we get
lower accuracy than random sampling so
but we wanted to show you know with
different uh strategies and with the
graph integrated how much it affects the
results so so this is what we get with
that
okay so if you want to uh
learn more details you can look at the
paper this is a kdt 2020 paper
um
so with that
let me see
um
we we also
uh so so this is the
the mimic
data we have this predefined ontology
but i mentioned the uh
the
cancer data and we want to apply the
cancer
you know
some kind of ontology on the cancer data
too so
this i just want to mention
uh the cancer also has maybe
not a predefined ontology but
they have based on the
data set you can build
hierarchy
with the data so we did not do that but
i hope to point out if you are
interested you can look into this
how to build the ontology based on the
the
data in the tcga for this purpose
because there is no predefined
relationship between the cancers
in general so you have to build based on
specific data
so this is a potential
interesting research people can look
into
um so
uh lastly before i finish
my talk i also to mention a potential
research you know
for the lab people can think about
which may be interesting to you because
this can be applied to both cancer and
alzheimer's or other diseases so that is
how to apply the methylene approach for
survivor analysis
so so basically uh the survivor analysis
uh have some unique features so the deep
learning may be
good to apply so so for example in the
tcga
pan cancer data set
or you in the ad
admin and adsp
disease dataset
so you have
a lot of features
and you have a lot of samples
and you also have this uh
survivor uh data
indicated
when
the the
the
sample died
and
but
the challenging issue is you have
probably 78 percent are censored so
censored means the
the subject leaves before event occurs
so you don't know when they they died so
or when they had the alzheimer's disease
they left early so those
in the uh survival analysis the domain
is called the sensor data
so in
so
in the in the in the uh you know
survivor analysis has been going on for
a long long time so there are many
survival models cox is the most famous
model uh
so the issue is how to integrate those
models
into the metadata process
so
the basic
concept you have the censored and
uncensored patient so if you only use
the uncensored
patients
which you know
when the event happened
then that's more accurate but the the
problem is like as i said you know most
of the data sets
don't have the the that information so
you so how do you deal with such a
sensor data you probably don't want to
just get rid of it because they then you
lose a lot of the information
so here we we actually uh
propose the to use deep learning to
directly learn a survival distribution
from data not using the cox model
because
you can you can learn the the uh
distribution just the you know utilizing
the best
uh you know time they they left so when
they left
and
a sample left earlier
than another sample you can consider
uh
that has a a a different the time of a
event may happen so the later one will
have a bad you know a later sum so using
those relationship
we can uh learn using different new
model for the sensor data make a a a
prediction of the distribution so that's
what
we we we
uh currently working on so so basically
uh
so since uh uh
you know patients live up to the
censored time so so we just
in in our uh
deep learning model we just you use the
log like there's a survival probability
before sensory time as the log
likelihood so so we are maximizing
whether we know based on the data
then we we use ranking to to rank the
relative risk of patients so that's uh
so uh how we we will we deal with
censored samples
in fact there are other papers they
recently show uh this can perform
better than the cox model uh utilizing
this sensor the data
in the uh survival analysis so this is
uh what uh we do so in the model i will
not go uh details about
uh the model
but uh we we will so so so basically in
the formula we will indicate
which are the sensors which are not
sensor and then we can build the
optimization function to
learn the distribution based on the data
so that's
what
we
have with how we handle the
the survival model part
so
uh with that uh so the metal uh survivor
lanyard so
in order to incorporating that into the
uh
you know metal menu
so we we have a uh you know as i
mentioned the metal revenue and the base
learning models i introduced the uma
they can
train and and
to be able to adapt to the new
environment so but in order to integrate
the survival analysis into the meta
renewal
so
in the metal survivor the survival model
is designed so survival model is as a
baseliner so you learn the basic
survival analysis based on what i just
mentioned
so we should so you you will
make a predictions for different
patients with different
cancers for example or alzheimer's
diseases
and
so
and then using the same principle the
survival model will fast adapter to the
prediction context
so it's a similar
principle the only difference is that
you train that
survival model
inside of a big the uh the metal randy
so
um
so so then the prediction made by the
survivor will continue on a specific
disease under
uh the metal renewal uh process
so
uh so so that's the
the
the
general idea
so
now here we are what we are working on
here is we try to use
knowledge more into the
matter survival model so so we we have a
so now more customized here not a very
general because
in terms of
the
biomedical so we build a knowledge
repository uh which you know indicating
so the related samples okay so the
samples uh in a customized way from the
repository so to con construct
some context
so in order so so that if we can
construct
such a context for survival uh
prediction
then we can make a better uh prediction
model so specifically uh two kind of uh
the
sample knowledge or context we build the
first one is difficulty awareness
so this we can recognize you know
prediction difficulty of a given patient
sample related to other samples in the
repository so
uh so so we have the set of uh patients
then we can assign attention so if you
have
learned this attention model in in the
nlp
uh modeling so we
assign attention to each of these
samples so we
build a
sample set which
you know to realize the context of
difficulty in the samples
and
in addition to that we also
indicating the heterogeneity awareness
which identifies how a given sample is
different from
other samples in the repository
so and please so then place the survival
model
at a proper position uh in its uh
parameter space
so so these are the current
contacts that we considered
model
uh so
um so uh so
to be a little bit specific this is a
general framework we we have been
building uh
uh
in our meta survival analysis with
knowledge so we we so so here you can
see here
uh
i strongly believe the knowledge from
the biometric domain can play a very big
law in the machine learning process
so and how much of this you can
generalize to different
uh
you know different domains of diseases
that's a
a different issue but the general
framework should be able to apply to
different
domains
so so basically on the left of this
figure you can see we can
we can track the context of samples and
with the graph
of the knowledge in the domain
and then we can you know integrate this
into our training of the meta learning
process
and and
so with difficulty and
heterogeneity
then also we incorporate the so we can
incorporate the survival model
and
into this
process so that's currently what we are
building uh for the survival analysis
model so we have some results but
i do not uh have the tables to
to report
uh you know a complete table to report
here but uh i i strongly believe in
covering the domain knowledge
is
very effective to build a better
uh
metal a new model for knowledge transfer
okay so that's uh mostly uh i hope here
they
encourage some of the um
you know
some of the interest
into this research for the lab
um so now i so i'm going to finish up
with my slide here
so
basically in a conclusion so if we
demonstrated the ability the ability of
metal learning uh memo and other uh
parts so how to predict cancer type and
survival uh
survival time so that's
so then
with this we can build a model that can
classify rare
cancers so that's the main point to
classify the rare cancers with new
subtypes you obtain just a few samples
you can quickly adapt it to the new
samples
but i should point out there's still a
long way to go there are many
interesting problem in health and bio
informatics
for which so the new machine learning
methods can help
i i do think that the new uh machine
learning methods can help
but
it does need uh both you know the the
very close collaboration between the
computer scientists and the domain
experts so that you know we can uh
incorporating domain knowledge
into the
prediction models so that's the whole
point that i hope to make here since the
lab has both data scientists
and biomedical uh domain people so i i
think you know working
closely between the two sides
we can generate a good
ideas and results
so uh with that i hope to
mention some of the
acknowledgement
so basically the nsf support
and also my students who contributed to
this presentation
so i basically
finished the on the
based on the budgeted time
i will be able to answer some questions
hey dong thank you so much that was uh
wonderful uh really great synopsis of of
uh it's kind of meta learning uh
applications and and you covered a lot
of ground thank you so much um one of
the things which i was kind of wondering
as you were presenting is
when you kind of know beforehand
what your training samples happen to be
um you know like where you have the
different types of cancers or for
example you know your your early example
of looking at
the faces of animals or something and
trying to identify kind of how what's
the minimum amount you need in order to
kind of get the meta learning things
started
nevertheless you kind of have to kind of
specify
a priori at the same time that's kind of
a static you know that's a static data
set in a sense and then you hope to be
able to apply it later on to you know
new exemplars
i guess where i'm going with this
question is
this almost seems like it would have a
lot of applicability in streaming
information as you're getting
information it's kind of like flowing in
um to a system and being able to in a
very quick amount of time begin the meta
bootstrapping the metal learning process
and then being able to uh perform
classifications as data is streaming in
do you have any
ideas about how you might apply that and
you know
there's a you know number of like
biomedical or neuropsyc neuro
neuro scientific data types that might
be like that that might be very
appropriate for a modeling system like
this
does that make sense
yeah but that that's an interesting
question
so basically you're thinking you have a
streaming data so uh but are you
assuming
the streaming data will will be new type
new type of data
or is the same data
uh it would like be well you know for
example uh it might be
electroencephalographic data so it's uh
multiple channels of electrical activity
coming you know from someone's brain
could one uh build a meta learning
system that starts reading that in and
starts using it as it's streaming in you
know the person's performing or behaving
or thinking or there's mental activity
going on
and the system could use that
information to perform meta learning
about generalized things but then when
asked to do specific things the model
might adapt and learn from it itself
yeah
that's a very interesting
you know
thinking because
i i haven't seen people doing that but
you know in principle
uh you have a you are streaming you have
a different
type of you know data coming right so
you can form
tasks you know in terms of tasks
different different tasks and to extract
the
most common features among these tasks
right and then
then you can quickly you know jump into
the new uh data coming and you can make
a prediction
that's what i'm kind of wondering is you
could like have the system just start
not knowing anything and just start
reading the stream and as you know
there's you know different tasks or
something are happening um it might be
able to learn the general principles and
then you could you know you could build
up a knowledge base of how that stream
should be coming and interpreted and
then you could throw curve balls at it
meaning you could change the tasks
slightly and see if how quickly it
adapts to the new yeah task
yeah i i i think it can work
you know
but it doesn't need to
experiment uh
of course
yeah i think in principle it should
you know it's a possible it's a
potential application
yeah
just you know thinking about that as a
possibility um
also uh what
you mentioned that can also be kind of
used to um take
look at images um you gave an example of
course of of animals i'm curious if
you've attempted to apply this to
any say microscopy data the data coming
from microscopes to do uh you know look
at different cell types or something
yeah yeah we did not do that yet but
certainly this is a one kind of
application you can do
yeah
i mean there's pl there's plenty of that
data around so it would be kind of
interesting to see it apply
yeah
um and another uh
thing would be like in human neuro
imaging where you have time series data
for example or you have different
subjects uh different patient groups for
example um and being able to use this to
try to classify some of the neural
imaging data
yeah that's uh actually
so
uh in the computer vision domain
originally this
proposed
was
used for those common images or
different images so i think it will be
uh you know very
likely to be effective
in those
you know images you just mentioned
yeah
hey don what do you see as being an
important element
for
biomedical scientists where data
scientists can play an important role
uh
i guess yeah that's a very
important question
so
in fact i just taught
a class for biomedical department they
created this new course called
data mining and machine learning for bio
medical engineers
so
yeah i just finished the course and i
believe
there is a gap
be you know between the data scientists
and the biomedical uh researchers
uh because i
i feel
uh the
the the the tools biomedical data
biomedical scientists use are still very
basic
basic tools
and and so mostly you know
uh
statistical oriented tools so i believe
there is a gap between
how much you can use
you know from the machine learning data
science side to the biomedical
research
so that neither really needs both side
work very close
in the
problem solving
i think
yeah i appreciated your comment uh there
in your conclusions and you have it up
on the screen now that uh that close
collaboration is really important
between computer scientists data
scientists people doing analysis um so
that these machine learning methods can
be kind of incorporated that those
prediction models actually mean
something and the predictions are are
valuable but you're not going to you're
not going to get that unless there's
close collaboration and team science
kind of approach would you agree
yeah yeah
fantastic
well
with that uh adong zhang from here at
the university of virginia thank you so
much for sharing your work with us today
that was really fantastic um for
everyone who joined us uh thank you so
much for doing so um everybody have a
wonderful weekend and we'll see you next
week for our final in this series of
biomedical data science uh innovation
lab seminar series
take care everybody bye